hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
this video is not about me today this is
about my grandad now my grandad is the
kindest
sweetest most generous person you'll
ever meet he believed in me when i was a
teenager he gave me my very first
business lesson and a long time ago now
my granddad actually made some writings
he wrote a book
and his dream was always to get this
published but the problem is
he lost all of the writings this is the
only copy in the world
and he has no idea what we're gonna do
what we're gonna do because he's always
wanted to publish a book but no one's
ever given him the opportunity or giving
him a break to do it
over lockdown we've taken these writings
we've typed them up me and my wife
amanda onto the computer
we've published the book we've designed
a cover and it is now on amazon and the
book has sold over a thousand copies
my grandad has no clue about this so
we're gonna drive around his house now
in wolverhampton and we're gonna give
him
his book ask him to sign us a copy and
let him know that he's received a little
bit of royalties from the book as well i
am
ridiculously excited
so the books are hidden
in my jumper and
we're all good i might leave them here
for now actually come back and get them
we have published it you've published it
so good it's oh
it's now on amazon oh that is the copper
oh isn't that full
that's true oh sam that's
brilliant that's how much we loved it
yeah oh this is brilliant
that you pleased aren't you from i can't
believe it
oh
[Music]
i think so far we've sold about a
thousand copies
yeah yeah
is
[Music]
yeah um
if you can sign it for me and amanda
here that would be great
oh that's wonderful that's it on amazon
but you never expected that did you bro
i couldn't believe
it i couldn't believe it
yeah what do you think that right
god not ready today yes it came
about ten days ago was when we first got
our coffee
but and we were gonna come around last
monday but then when we on sunday night
we were getting ready to come out and
then we found out granddad had gone to
hospital
and we were thinking well you better
come out
come out yeah then we knew that they
weren't doing any visitors
at new cross so we've just been thinking
we've just been praying and waiting for
for mana to get out um so we're going to
hear that you got over the weekend
and that's why i wanted to quickly come
today
oh i can't believe it
clever well i have not done much
i just literally um read it amanda typed
it up new designed the cover and then we
just passed it over to our
publishers what was she thinking and she
was reading it oh
yeah very it was like let's get on to
the next chapter
i can't believe the
yeah you're like this you just need to
listen
to your copy right now secrets from
author brian browning
[Music]
and it's currently on five stars on
amazon
what is it your favorite one
the fruits of your liver granddad yeah
the fruits of your labour
just over a thousand pounds
it's in your bank now
got a nice little bonus there you'll
have to get him writing more books
grandma
[Laughter]
i think you should have started earlier
writing books you had [ __ ] up on the
computer
originally originally and then what
happened
lost it so we took this back home with
us
and read it and it was actually really
good wasn't it yeah
it was such a good book that we've
published it on behalf of my grandad
what did you think when you when you saw
it what did you think i was shocked
just that you'd done it i thought you
did a terrific job
[Music]
grandad if you're watching this i love
you absolutely loads and
honestly anyone else that's watching
this i think it's really important to
remember sometimes that giving
feels better than to receive even and i
loved giving the gift of my granddad's
book but i also loved reading it so if
you're watching
this and you'd like to read the book
then you can order it from amazon i'll
leave a link in the description support
my grandad
check the book out and let me know what
you think honestly thank you so much for
everyone that's subscribed to my channel
that watches my videos
i know this has been a little bit
different normally i talk about how to
make money in property and this is just
something a little bit different but
i had to film it when i went around to
my granddad's house and it was just
priceless so granddad you're amazing
thank you for watching i'll see you next
[Music]
time and i
will when the sky is falling